hi everyone this is shooting today I'll
walk you through a day in the life
it's 9:00 a.m. and I just got to work
first up is coffee so it gets
[Music]
so now it's almost 10 o'clock and time
to go to stand up meeting stand up
meeting is a meeting where the team
members get together and they meet in a
room and to talk about three things what
they did yesterday what they're gonna be
working on today and if there are new
blockers so let me take you to my
stand-up meeting
[Music]
[Music]
let's go get some lunch now I have a
one-on-one with my manager and my
one-on-ones with my manager usually talk
about some of the things that are going
well some of the things that I would
like to change if there's any and it's
pretty informal meeting we should go to
noir grab some coffees and it's an hour
long meeting so I'll see you in an hour
[Music]
one of our interns Jobo is leaving
PayPal today this is his last day so
we're gonna give him a farewell so that
was my day I hope you had fun let me
know in the comments below what was your
favorite part you can also send me a
message on twitter i should think 4:08
if you have any questions thank you for
watching how your day bye